à l'aube de la cinquantaine mathieu
quiviger s'attaquent de plus un temps au
défi le plus exigeant de sa vie
professionnelle
ce diplômé en architecture est un touche
à tout elle a écrit des romans à jouer
pour les alouettes et a notamment
entraîné le rendu et renée tardif la
ligne à l'attaqué est absolument
extraordinaire
en plus d'être analyste à la télé
deux jours avant la rentrée des classes
en 2019 un ami lui a proposé de venir
enseigner en 5e année à son école le
lendemain j'ai parlé au directeur dans
l'après-midi à 2h30
c est ce pays à prouver mon ma
candidature et le lendemain matin à 7h50
j'étais devant une classe de 25 élèves
de 5e année donc c'est fulgurant qui n'a
pas remarqué qu'il y avait des et rage
ce colosse qui mesure près de 2 mètres
ans est aujourd'hui en 6e année dans un
milieu déstabilisé par lapandry
il gagne en aisance grâce à l'aide
inestimable reçu de ses collègues dont
je m'attendais à peut-être une réception
un peu froide ça c'est tout contre moi
je chante carré par des profs absolument
essentiel des gens qui répondent à
toutes mes questions aussi stupide soit
elle des gens qui m'ont poussé dès le
début kim ont encadré le directeur de
l'école reconnaît que ce type d'embauché
est inévitable en raison de pénurie
d'enseignants
de par sa stature déjà il en impose dans
commence à parler un petit peu de son
véhicule
je pense à mon avis avec mon expérience
que déjà ils capables d'aller chercher
quelques garçons en place qui des fois
on ne l'est plus à discuter si d'anti
fier à la personne qui est en avant
cliquez pour l'avenir
[Musique]
au printemps dernier mathieu quiviger à
d'enseigner à distance de son chalet
très à l'aise devant la caméra et avec
les technologies il était en confiance
sa première fois de l'année que j'avais
peut-être un petit avantage sous livre
est prof et même cette aide je trouve
qu'on s'est beaucoup rapproché des gens
il s'agit mon dieu c'est répétitif
armand strabon son passé d'entraîneur du
tout c'est de bien gérer sa classe il
adore sa nouvelle vie où si exigeante
soit elle moi je comprends mieux que
jamais les professeurs action usés après
12 ans 15 ans 20 en enseignements c'est
une énergie que mon âge et j'en profite
parce que je n'aurais cru je sais pas si
dans dix ans voire la même énergie la
même la même passion la même et il a
même pas ce qu'il faut contacter chacun
aura le mérite il parfois le syndrome de
l'imposteur jallieu toute ma vie sauf
dans ce métier 4 soit un enfant à son
bureau qu'il a vu le talent comprend
d'avoir damas que tout bon pour la
première fois qui dit merci ça s'est
saisie si tu y trouves tu vois la c ie
taper les enfants sont tellement vrai
dans les émotions que l'impact de tout
ce que tu fais tu veux que je te vois là
d'un mouvement ce matin ça va mieux si
je lui donnais un c'est plus qu'un qui
est arrivé ben j'aurais pas de
difficulté à lui donner maintenant au
moins fait partie arrivera qu'ils
veulent de moi tu as quand les enfants
ont besoin de moins pressés qui c'est
antoine des réseaux canada montréal